this is a production of Cornell
University
one so today if any mentioned we're
gonna talk a little bit about my work on
organic no-till soybeans systems so I
don't have enough time to share all the
work that I've been involved in over the
last two years but I want to do at least
introduce you to some of the projects
that I have been working on a Cornell
and really I've been involved in five
main projects that we can organize under
three main topics or themes so the first
one is winter serial thermal models so
we're working with cereal rye barley and
triticale twelve cultivars across those
species so this work is in New York as
well as in Maryland where we're working
with Steven mercy at the USDA so this is
really gonna help us predict phenology
and cover crop biomass speak a little
yes I can I will try to thank you
so we're also working on the trade offs
looking at the trade-offs between forage
quality and yield for winter cereals
that are grown as forage double crops so
double cropping systems that dairy
producers might be employing on their
farm and so this work is with Korean
Kettering's
and a really big group of Extension
educators and farmers we have a lot of
sites throughout New York as well as
Maryland so it's been a lot of fun to
work with such a big team and then
finally my last three projects really
fall under the umbrella of these cover
crop based organic rotational no-till
soybeans systems and so that uses a
roller crimper which you can kind of see
this implement on the front of the
tractor here it's used to terminate the
cover crops so roll them down flat and
I'm going to talk about this at length
and so these projects range from system
economics all the way to a focus more on
weed ecology and so today I'm going to
talk about one of these projects where
we're looking at mixtures of barley and
cereal rye to enhance weed suppression
in these systems and these aren't just
you know disparate projects there is a
common thread here and that's that they
all involve winter cereals so either as
a cover crop for weed suppression or as
forage for dairy producers so other than
a really long name what is cover crop
based organic rotational knows your
soybean some of you might not be
familiar with this system this
photograph is from the Musgrave research
bar
in New York and so what I've highlighted
here this is how you would typically
prepare the soil so you have your
primary tillage your secondary tillage
and then you can come in and plant for
instance your soybean crop so in
contrast to that with these cover crop
based systems you need to start with a
cover crop in the fall so what you're
looking at here is cereal rye and barley
this would be planted in mid-september
and then when it reaches an thesis so
mid to early June so I should say mid
May through early June they're ready to
be terminated with the roller crimper
and that's what it looks like after that
roller crimper is passed over those
cover crops forming a nice thick cover
crop mulch that provides your weed
suppression and then you can no-till
plant through that cover crop mulch for
these no.2 based systems so we've
established you have your tillage based
management and then your cover crop base
no-till and so why would farmers be
interested in this different type of
soybean production if you think back to
2013 we had a really wet June and August
in the Northeast and if we look at a
photo from Aurora you can see a lot of
surface erosion washing out of soybeans
here in these tillage based systems and
then up lots Jayson to it you can see
that the soybeans are growing up
undisturbed through this thick cover
crop mulch later on surface sealing of
those clay soils you see standing water
and then again those cover crop based
system is just fine and so this is one
of the main reasons farmers are interest
in this system and that's from a soil
health perspective so in addition to
reducing erosion a lot of researchers
looked at increasing biodiversity so
both below ground and above ground
obviously associated with reduced
tillage or disturbance in these
rotational no-till systems when we think
of system advantages it's really for
conventional and organic growers so for
a conventional grower that might be
struggling with herbicide resistant
weeds we can think of this as an
integrated weed management approach so
in a really simplified way you can think
of these cover crops is replacing your
synthetic herbicides and for organic
growers that would be replacing your
cultivation but of course these cover
crops provide many other better
I forgot to mention here when you're
comparing it to tillage based organic
production we see about a 30% reduction
in diesel fuel and labor and what's
interesting when you talk to farmers or
grower meetings they're really drawn to
this from a soil health perspective we
can talk about energy savings but it's
really about reducing tillage in their
crop rotation and that's what's really
driving them towards adopting this type
of management system so this all sounds
pretty good you know is this the new
perspective of farmers when you're
sitting on their tractor you got the
roller crimper out front looking at a
field of winter cereals rather you roll
that down I mean we hope so that's what
we're working on we're working right now
on a farmer manual to help address some
of these issues that farmers are coming
up against so issues related to weed
suppression in particular and one of the
most common questions that we get at
grower meetings is how does this fit
into my rotation farmers are typically
planting if you think of a corn soybean
wheat rotation soybean would be
following corn grain and so for this
system to work they would be
establishing a winter cereal like cereal
rye after they've harvested corn grain
and that's going to be really late in
the fall and is not going to provide
enough biomass or uniform stand for weed
suppression so right off the bat that's
going to be a real trouble a real
problem for farmers if they're stuck in
this corn soybean wheat rotation so from
my perspective I'm interested in kind of
a food grain based system that might
have more small grains so something like
wheat would be a really good crop to
proceed this so we it's gonna be
harvested in August and it gives you
lots of time to establish something like
cereal rye in early September if you're
working on a feed grain based system a
short season corn silage would work and
that's gonna push you maybe into
mid-september for establishing that
cover crop and what I want to draw your
attention to if you look at these later
planting dates so these are six
different cereal rice eating dates these
photographs were taken on April 1st and
if you notice that these later planting
dates along the bottom you see a lot
more soil between those rows of cob
crops and where you see exposed soil
that's where weed seeds are going to
germinate and that's a real problem
because in this system it's those early
emerging weeds that really dominate so
you've got wild buckwheat common ragweed
they're gonna emerge before you actually
roll that cover crop in late May so as
you can see here that come up in that
stand in this case it's cereal rye in
the background here so if you look at
some of these data from Pennsylvania you
can see common ragweed here in these
violin plots emerge a lot earlier than
other common summer annual weeds so that
bulge in this plot here indicates that
the majority of that species is emerging
in this case an early April in New York
we would expect this to be a few weeks
later but that's still gonna be the
majority of them emerging before we roll
down these cover crops and so that's a
real problem because common ragweed
emerges early and it also can survive
rolling and crimping and this has really
informed a lot of our research this is
not just a phenomenon on the musgrave
research farm this is throughout the
Northeast this common rag we just
dominates in these cover crop based
no-till soybeans systems so in terms of
previous research the focus has really
been on maximizing cereal rye biomass so
manipulating seeding date and seeding
rate and a couple of the factors like
that emerging from that as being this
threshold of 8,000 kilograms per hectare
and it's been suggested that if you can
achieve that you're gonna get consistent
or adequate weed suppression throughout
the season but there's some problems
with that with this a successive cover
crop production and that's lodging what
you see here and really fertile soils
and it's also really difficult to get
good seed to soil contact it's really
hard to get good soybean seed placement
through a thick mulch so in this photo
here you can see that they've added
sandbags on top of these planter units
to try to get more down pressure so you
can actually penetrate that thick cover
crop mulch and get good seed to soil
contact and this is particularly
challenging if it's dry in the spring
and later on obviously if you don't get
that good soybean seed placement
germination is going to be poor and some
of these soybeans that do emerge you can
see our pretty chlorotic and you're
going to see a yield loss so for our
research and the way differs from
this previous research is that we're
moving away from focus on this maximum
biomass and instead we're focusing on
optimizing early-season shading for
optimal or for better weed suppression
and so to do that we're looking at
mixtures of barley and cereal rye
so cereal are as tall and slender barley
is going to be shorter wider leaves and
I'm not suggesting that this is really a
true niche differentiation as you would
expect with the leggy amana cereal but
these slight differences in phenology
stature and leaf architecture might be
enough to give us that edge provide
better early season shading so we've got
a couple objectives we're interested in
the impact of these cover crop mixtures
on weed suppression as well as
ultimately on soybean yields and then
we're looking at two main management
treatments so high residue cultivation
and then just standard no-till and again
we're looking at those in those effects
on weed suppression and soybean yield in
terms of experiment design we used a
split block design so replicated four
times over two years this was 2012 to
2014 at the musgrave research farm we
seeded our cover crops in a replacement
series so you've got a barley
monoculture a 50-50 mixture and then a
cereal rye monoculture and these were
seeded as I mentioned mid-september at
19 centimeter row spacing I will note
that I have some photographs in here
from 2013 but all the data I'm going to
share is just from 2014 I really just
have time to share a subset of all the
different treatments that were involved
in this experiments so we're just going
to simplify this in the interest of time
all right
as I mentioned you've got your two
management treatments standard no-till
which is going to involve rolling
crimping that cover crop when they're a
ten thesis and then no-till planting
soybeans on that same day and that's it
you don't have to do anything else until
you come in a harvest that soybean in
October with high residue cultivation on
this about two to four weeks after
you've planted that soybean you're gonna
have a single pass with a high residue
cultivator to control some inter oh we'd
and this is one of the reasons why we
use these wider soybean spacing so
seventy six centimeter rows so it
facilitates the operation
this high residue cultivator and we did
include adjacent to those plots an
integral cultivated treatment and so
this would allow us to compare these
cover crop based management practices to
what would be kind of your traditional
tillage based soybean management so to
look at this roller crimper a little
more closely it basically involves a
cylinder with these blunt metal blades
welded in a chevron pattern and it's
gonna bend or crimp these plants at
their base as opposed to shearing or
cutting them off as a mower would and
this is an important distinction because
we want that cover crop mulch to persist
throughout the season and when you mow
these cover crops down which has been
looked at another research it's of
course going to increase the surface
area which is going to speed up
decomposition which is going to result
in poor weed suppression with the hybrid
cultivator after those cover crops being
rolled this implement has really wide
sweeps on it that are intended to slice
through the soil just below the soil
surface it's going to sever wheat shoots
from weed roots and has really thin
shanks with the intention of limiting
the amount of residue that's dragged all
over the field so this photo kind of
shows that we had some trouble actually
I'm calibrating this equipment we didn't
get enough cover crop biomass and you
can see some soil that's actually turned
out between the rows ideally you
wouldn't see anything you barely notice
that this piece of equipment has been
run through the field in terms of
seeding rates we based our replacement
series on Aroostook rye and then we
adjusted for differences in size and
mass for the barley seed which is why we
refer to this as density based seedings
as opposed to volume based seedings so
the slow density is equivalent to a 1
bushel per acre and then this high
density is two bushels per acre you'll
notice the soybean this is a really high
seeding rate that's about 300,000 seeds
per acre which is so double conventional
soybean seeding rates and if you think
about herbicide based conventional
soybean production these are essentially
weed free systems with the exception of
issues with herbicide tolerant weeds so
you're going to have really high
germination rates for the soybean really
good ceiling survival obviously very
little to no we
petition and so you can use those lower
soybeans seeding rates and still get
maximum yield but for us this is really
part of our cultural weed management so
we use these high rates to achieve
canopy closure earlier in the season
which is going to provide greater
shading which is going to reduce the
fecundity of weeds so some of these
later emerging summer annuals so in
other words less seed production from
some of those later species so this in
concert with that rolled mulch really
forms the basis of our weed suppression
and this photos a little bit dark here
but what you're seeing is a shot from
underneath that soybean canopy here
that's completely closed you just see a
little bit of sunlight filtering through
and then you see that nice rolled cover
crop mulch there along the soil surface
in terms of sampling before those cover
crops were rolled we measured cover crop
biomass and population
photosynthetically active radiation or
light transmittance through that cover
crop canopy and then after they were
rolled weed identification we looked at
weed biomass and then also soybean
density and yield we certainly measured
a lot of other things but again this is
just a subset of this experiment so this
is what we're going to focus on so if we
look at the interspecific cover crop
competition we've got cover crop biomass
on the y-axis and those replacements
series so that seeding ratio along the
x-axis and you've got your low density
and high density seeding rates and what
you'll notice here in the low density is
that I just first mentioned this depth
these dashed lines are your barley
monoculture and these dotted lines are
your cereal rye monoculture and then the
solid lines here are your 50-50 mixtures
and so what you're seeing here is what
we term over yielding at that low
density so in other words this is a
higher absolute yield in that 50/50
mixture of barley and cereal rye
compared to a cereal rye monoculture
orally the barley monoculture here and
with these studies typically that's what
you're looking for maybe if it's a
legume and it's a cereal you want over
yielding especially if these are being
grown for grain but for our purposes
we're really more interested in shading
so does this higher biomass here
actually translate into enhanced shading
and that's better
you control and I'll also just know we
actually didn't see that in high density
and there's a number of different
reasons here perhaps the CRI has greater
competitive ability especially in what
would be considered more resource
limited environment so when we look at
par transmittance so that light that
actually is making it through that
canopy we have the same seating ratios
along the bottom we actually don't see
enhanced shading in that 50/50 mixture
so instead you see that part
transmittance increases as the
proportion of cereal rye decreases so in
other words at that serie where I
monoculture that's where you see the
least amount of light reaching the soil
surface and in that barley monoculture
that's where the greatest amount of
light is actually making it through and
when you look at weed biomass across
those seeing ratios you see a really
similar trend as you might expect of
course if there's more light coming
through the canopy you're gonna have
great greater weed germination higher
weed biomass and of course less weed
bomb-ass when there's less light making
it through the canopy we saw this really
clearly in the field you have your
barley monoculture here and that is a
lot of common ragweed that's that's
emerged so we really did not have nearly
enough biomass production there or of
course shading to suppress those weeds
with the cereal rye monoculture we had
actually pretty good pretty adequate
weed suppression through most of our
treatments when we look at total weed
biomass you can see that common ragweed
comprised over 80% of that biomass so it
was really dominant in this system we
had foxtail species so yellow and giant
foxtail made up about 8% and then a
variety of other weeds made up the
remaining 10% for this experiment so if
we're gonna then focus on common ragweed
let's look at those management
treatments so we've got common ragweed
biomass here you've got let's look at
the difference of high residue
cultivation and standard no-till and
what we saw was about a 20 to 30 percent
reduction when you integrate that high
residue cultivation and of course you
can see by the error bars this wasn't a
significant reduction but if you think
of this from a farmer's perspective or a
more applied perspective
reducing common ragweed biomass by a few
hundred kilograms it's going to be
really important for long-term weed seed
bank management so there's gonna be a
lot lower contribution of weed seeds
that are going to be a problem later on
in their rotation and this photos from
2013 and I just wanted to use this to
illustrate how effective that high
residue cultivation can be so these
lighter rows here are soybeans that are
ready to be harvested and what you'll
notice in the standard no.2 all this
dark these dark patches here all of that
is Colin ragweed so when you look at the
hybrid cultivation you can see no home
and ragweed at all in between those rows
so under certain conditions this can be
really really effective at taking care
of that inter-row common ragweed alright
and here what we're really interested in
is is shading a really good predictor of
common ragweed biomass so you've got
common ragweed biomass on the y-axis
again we have common or cover crop
biomass so combine both barley and
cereal rye biomass here and then par
transmittance on this right right side
chart and so really you can think of
this as a lot of the previous research
is focused on this relationship just
maximizing cover crop biomass whereas
we've shifted the focus over here to par
transmittance or shading and what we
found both in the low end high-density
treatments as well as all the other
treatments I couldn't discuss was that
in fact shading was a much better
predictor of common ragweed so you can
see here we definitely had higher
r-squared values when we look at this
relationship and what's interesting to
note is as we saw with the low density
in that high or that over yielding and
that lower density treatment high
biomass production doesn't necessarily
result in greater shading so it
definitely suggests to us that we really
need to focus in on shading to really
tackle this issue of early emerging
weeds like common ragweed in terms of
soybean yield we actually saw no
differences between seeding ratio or
management treatments which was
surprising given the differences in
cover crop biomass as well as weed
biomass and on average we got about 40
bushels per acre which is actually the
lowest yields we had across all of our
different
and our on-farm sites we typically get
45 to 50 bushels which is really
competitive with other organically
produced soybeans so tillage based
systems when we compare this to the
intro cultivation we see about 80% of
that yield and so that's definitely a
substantial yield loss there again this
is a little bit related to these were
not very productive treatments for us
and of course you need to factor in the
fact that there's going to be a 30
percent reduction in diesel fuel and
labor with this type of management so in
summary we found that early season
shading definitely was an important
predictor
we're coming driver of common ragweed
biomass but these mixtures of barley and
cereal rye might not be the best way to
actually achieve that enhanced shading
we're definitely encouraged to continue
pursuing this because pre-empting that
common ragweed biomass is just so
critical for addressing these issues for
farmers in the Northeast I also found
that high residue cultivation was really
useful for controlling that inter-row
common ragweed and you can think of it
as a rescue cultivation and for long
term weed seed bank management this
might be a really useful tool and then
this is actually different than what
we'd expected soybean yield was not
higher when you integrated that high
residue cultivation that's in some ways
this might be a desirable result for us
because what it suggests is if we focus
on cover crop management and so we can
really suppress those weeds with just
standard no-till you're not gonna see a
yield loss if you don't integrate high
residue cultivation and really for
farmers they're not that interested when
we've gone to grow armies and talked
about this in using high residue
cultivator because the whole purpose or
their whole interest in this is a
reduced tillage system so this idea of
higher education is is it's not very
popular and we definitely see a high
potential profitability for this system
like I said if you get these competitive
yields in combination with this
reduction in energy use this is going to
translate into higher profits for
farmers and so with that I just like to
thank particularly Chris Pelzer Brian
Caldwell and the rest of our lab and all
the folks at the Musgrave Research Forum
I certainly could have done this Reece
which without everyone's assistance and
support so there's time I'd love to take
some questions thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu